now some people say our curiosity gets
us into trouble right
our insistence on asking questions our
insistence on probing away at the
mysteries of
being and tinkering with nature has
inevitably gotten us into trouble
now certainly there are unintended
consequences to our probing
certainly when you play with fire you
might
get burned but my friends what defines
us is our exploratory itch what defines
us
is our fire in the belly to be human
is to transcend our limits to be human
is to overcome
our boundaries when we dream of space
exploration
we dream of transcendence we dream
of what we might become our boredom
our jadedness our refusal to heed the
call
right our conformity comes from
fear it comes from us lacking the
courage to do what we're born to do to
do what we're designed to do
which is to probe to explore to
transcend
to heed that call to take that
journey to awaken the mind's attention
from the lethargy of custom
walker person perhaps said it best
the search is what anyone would
undertake if they were not
sunk drowning in the everydayness of
their own life
to become aware just to become aware
of the possibility of the search
is to be
[Music]
by the eyes we want to eat
new interpretable information we want to
take in information through the visual
cortex which occupies half our brain
which is connected to opioid receptors
we get high
from taking in new information we are
not herbivores we are not carnivores we
are infowars
right designed to desire to probe to
understand carl sagan said
understanding is a kind of ecstasy
isaiah berlin said
to understand is to perceive patterns
we are the music makers we are the
dreamers of dreams my friend
do not give up get out there
heed the call take the journey
the cave you fear holds the treasure you
seek
what you are seeking is seeking
you
[Music]